hi I'm Cece balagot and I play Frankie
Stein hi my name is Mia Harris and I
play Claudine Wolf hey I am Naya damson
and I play Draculaura and we're the cast
of Monster High the movie we're here
with BuzzFeed to play who's who
[Music]
yeah I do want to say me yeah well I
hate to pull like a a little oh yeah
we're all Lego characters but I feel
like in a way I think we all have
similarities yeah but Frankie has this
amazing talent of spewing random facts
right and it's so Niche and somebody
else who also has this very Niche Talent
yes yeah that's like one of Frankie's
like main characteristics is that they
don't know that they know everything
every once in a while a light bulb will
pop in their head and they'll like all
of a sudden speed this information it's
very much like me take the cake on that
one
foreign
yeah I mean I have that kind of
independent aspect of it but I wouldn't
tell you like no you stay over there and
I stay over here she's very elitist
Draculaura is you know she's all about
like everything has to be like exactly
this way and you're not really like
you're a little bit more like I wouldn't
say it I might think it will never say
anything Draculaura is a Scorpio so are
you yeah okay if anything
she is in knowledgeable about all of it
she knows the movies absolutely she
knows that she was originally like a big
Cleo fan she has several Cleo dolls and
she studied the original series she
studied but even she kept the diary as
Cleo yes we were filming she's learned
about like the mummy culture and
Cleopatra herself yes so she was like an
English major she's the righty righty
Reedy ready we love her
hmm
who always makes me laugh in the middle
of a tank in case oh yeah yeah he's so
funny and he like I don't know what it
is he does this look that just makes you
crack up yes I also admittedly will
purposely make Nia laugh I was gonna
give it to miss Mia Harris over here she
will be making faces during very serious
scenes like this like that
it's a long day you gotta keep it
light-hearted it's true what's one more
thing that's true
me easy oh thank you thank you okay so
Halloween costumes we're filming Monster
High it was Halloween we filmed in
Canada and we're not from Canada so we
had all the clothes that we packed and
we ended up pulling together a really
good Wizard of Oz costume exactly I told
them I'm like oh yeah I'm gonna be
Dorothy from Wizard of Oz and then we
all just were like we'll just grab what
we have yeah
the lion I was a scarecrow I was the
Wicked Witch yes dry was the witch case
was the Tin Man CeCe he is so crafty yes
like a needle some thread and fabric and
like this is actually by CeCe
a hundred percent the whole cast you
know we can't lay down in our beautiful
gorgeous expensive wigs so we have to
kind of sleep like Dracula actually like
this a little bit the end credits of the
movie actually if you pay attention very
closely there is a bit of a montage of
all of us sleeping like some creepy
monsters yeah
I do sometimes I also have tick tocks
that are relatable and then you know I
feel like Kyle and case are really good
participants this is the one like cast
group chat where like people do say
things often like we actually still talk
and like we'll send information and
pictures that we find yeah we're all
such good friends
okay wait I'm gonna give that to you
yeah because your movie you've been
telling me since the beginning your
favorite is Corpse Bride corporate is my
favorite movie of all time everybody
should watch it right and you're just
such a fall girlie thanks yeah you're
very spooky like you're all kind of
really edgy people like we like the
darker stuff you know we could all get
that one yes we like it's spooky season
for me 24
7.65 baby
[Music]
oh yes Lila Lila Ghoulia's character
apparently like according to the
director for her audition she was the
only one to go super full out with her
audition and every time she does
something it makes me giggle like she
goes 150 every single take
well if it's popcorn yeah Jai case will
like disappear and then come back with
just food you're right he just come back
he like well he's got a little bit more
often than us to be like I'll see you in
20 minutes and then come back with like
I got a sandwich and I got a muffin I
got a drink I got two things of coke We
snuck a little bit but mostly our snacks
are just candy that we've brought yeah
Lolly order on Amazon and then we bring
it yeah
lollipops we're helping nerds nerds
lollipops that are just pure sugar
literally 100 certain products yeah if
you ever want to know how to like be in
a movie filled with monsters you just
need sugar sugar yeah yes
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
so it was our last day and the only one
crying was me like they were hugging me
I feel like everybody was crying but
Naya cried I cried internally you cried
internally sure
I could internally I was sad but I'm
more I was more excited yeah
exactly I know we were so excited that
we did it yeah and and so Naya did all
the crying for us yeah it's okay I'll
take it
take it I could cry right now
thanks BuzzFeed and make sure you watch
Monster High the movie on Paramount plus
and Nickelodeon
[Music]